en este vídeo quiero mostrarles el
proceso de etiquetar voltajes en un
circuito que estamos por analizar esto
es algo que a veces causa estrés o
confusión pero aquí lo vamos a explicar
de manera que esto ya no no se estrese
lo primero que quiero hacer es que
recordemos la convención de signos para
los componentes pasivos decimos que sí
tenemos una resistencia por ejemplo y
etiquetamos un voltaje más menos de en
ella en el momento en el que etiquetemos
el sentido o la flecha de la corriente
siempre va a ir de la terminal positiva
del componente hacia la terminal
negativa en este caso es la resistencia
otro ejemplo es que si yo dibujo la
resistencia hacia acostada y si etiquetó
mi voltaje con el signo negativo de este
lado y el positivo de este otro lado
entonces cuando vaya a aplicar mi flecha
de corriente la voy a poner entrando por
el signo positivo del voltaje
esta es la convención de signos de un
componente pasivo
así es como etiquetamos el voltaje y la
corriente
para que ambos sean consistentes ahora
vamos a analizar el circuito aquí he
dibujado dos circuitos idénticos y vamos
a etiquetarlos de manera diferente lo
primero que hacemos al analizar un
circuito es definir las variables que
vamos a usar así que de este lado
etiquetó ahí así esta es una elección
que yo puedo hacer y también voy a
etiquetar los voltajes y elijo etiquetar
los voltajes así más y menos b1 para
esta resistencia 1 y aquí tengo más
menos de 2 ahora vamos a analizar este
circuito y vamos a darles valores a los
componentes aquí tendremos 10 oms y aquí
abajo tenemos 20 oms
ahora vamos a aplicar la ley de voltajes
de chirico en este circuito y veamos
cómo resulta la ley de voltajes de
kirkuk va a comenzar en este nodo de
aquí y vamos a analizar el circuito en
este sentido vamos a hacer unas
ecuaciones digamos que tenemos 3 volts
positivos al pasar por esta fuente de
aquí tenemos
una elevación de voltaje de 3 volts y
luego tenemos una caída de voltaje de
menos de 1 luego tendremos otra caída de
voltaje en b2 de nuevo pasamos de más a
menos menos de 2 igual a cero esta es
nuestra ecuación el fk para este
circuito de acá continuamos con el
análisis 3 volts menos b 1 es igual a la
corriente y por esta resistencia de 10
oms y por 10 y esta vez 2 es y por 2011
y esto es igual a 0
seguimos tenemos tres menos y por diez
más veinte igual a cero lo que significa
que es igual a menos tres entre 10 más
20 30 y el signo negativo se queda en
este 30 así que es igual a punto 1
amperes ya encontramos ahí y ahora vamos
a encontrar a las ves primero vamos a
resolver b 1 dijimos que b 1 en iguala y
por ere 1 b 1 es igual a y que es igual
a punto un amperes por 10 oms que nos va
a dar un volt de 2 va a ser igual apuntó
un amperes por 2011 igualados volts y
podemos hacer una última revisión y
sustituir esto en nuestra ecuación
original para ver si se cumple esta
ecuación lb acá así que 3 volts menos de
1 es un volt menos de 2 que es
volts es igual a cero y en efecto esto
se cumple y este fue un análisis
bastante sencillo de este circuito con
dos resistencias encontramos todas las
corrientes y voltajes ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo pero ahora voy a
etiquetar los voltajes de una manera
diferente aquí voy a definir a b1 como -
más de uno mantendremos a b2 como estaba
antes más menos de dos y ahora necesito
mi variable de corriente y la vamos a
etiquetar aquí como lo hicimos
anteriormente y en este punto me pueden
decir oye te equivocaste aquí esta no es
la etiqueta correcta de este voltaje
pero les quiero mostrar que vamos a
obtener la misma respuesta que en el
ejemplo anterior aún cuando puse mis
etiquetas de manera extraña así que
hagamos el mismo análisis lb acá para
este circuito y lo que les quiero
mostrar es que la aritmética que vamos a
hacer se encarga de los signos de manera
correcta así que la ecuación lv-ca para
este circuito dice
y comenzamos en el mismo lugar y vamos a
ir en esta misma dirección así que aquí
tenemos 3 volts un aumento de voltaje ya
que vamos de menos a más y ahora que
llegamos a r 1 vemos que tenemos 1 - más
es decir llegamos primero al signo
negativo y salimos por el signo positivo
así que tenemos más de uno es diferente
de lo que teníamos la vez anterior ya
que la vez anterior teníamos aquí un
menos de uno en cambio aquí tenemos un +
b 1 pero no se preocupen va a funcionar
bien ahora llegando a r2 nos encontramos
primero el más y luego al menos así que
tendremos una caída de voltaje tenemos
una resta y todo esto será igual a cero
tenemos diferentes ecuaciones pero
tenemos una definición diferente para b1
ahora quiero escribir estos voltajes en
términos de los valores de su
resistencia y la corriente y es aquí
donde usamos con cuidado la convención
de los signos ahora necesitamos incluir
un término que represente
no aplicamos la ley de ohm y en este
punto debemos ser cuidadosos la
corriente llega a la terminal negativa
de nuestra r1 así que vamos a decir que
b r 1 es igual a y negativa por r 1 lo
que tiene sentido ya que si definimos
que nuestra variable de corriente está
entrando por la terminal negativa
entonces la ley d hondt va a tener este
signo negativo aquí para que esto sea
correcto así que aquí abajo escribimos
menos y por ere 1 que es 10 oms y
llegamos a b 2 que ésta es la misma que
teníamos anteriormente menos b 2 que es
y por ere 2 que es 2011 y todo esto va a
ser igual a cero así que pueden ver en
esta ecuación que este signo negativo se
encuentra aquí porque aplicamos bien la
convención de signos para componentes
pasivos que es lo que hace que esta
ecuación se vea igual que esta de aquí
sigamos con el análisis menos y por 10
más 20 igual a 0 y ya tenemos la misma
ecuación que antes así que vamos a
obtener la misma y es igual este 3 pasa
del otro lado así que es menos 3 10 + 20
es 30 y lo pasamos con el signo negativo
por lo que tenemos menos 30 que es igual
a 0.1 amperes igual que en el ejemplo
anterior
ahora verifiquemos los voltajes y aquí
tenemos que notar que la dirección de
referencia la referencia de dirección
original que teníamos para ver nos
generó un signo negativo cuando usamos
la ley de ohm así que la seguimos usando
así que ve y es igual a menos y por r1
que es igual a menos punto 1 amperes por
10 oms lo que nos da menos un volt de 2
es igual a y por ere 2 que es igual
amperes por 22 que nos da igual a 2
volts y podemos ver la diferencia aquí
veo uno en este circuito es positivo ya
que tiene el signo positivo arriba y
resultó con un valor de un bol positivo
y en el otro circuito cuando volteamos a
b1 menos un volt aquí significa que esta
terminal de la resistencia está un volt
por debajo de esta otra terminal de la
resistencia lo que significa exactamente
lo mismo en este caso así que ambas
cosas en estos circuitos significan lo
mismo y por supuesto el voltaje 2
resultó ser el mismo así que el
propósito de esta demostración es que
vean que no importa como etiqueten los
voltajes en alguna parte de aquí como en
este caso la ley de voltajes de kirkuk
se encargará de mantener bien los signos
por lo que terminaremos con la misma
respuesta al final así que cuando nos
enfrentamos con el problema de poner
etiquetas en un circuito
no se preocupen ni se estresen por
tratar de adivinar con anticipación cómo
será el signo de estos voltajes
simplemente necesitan elegir una
orientación un sentido y seguirlo y la
aritmética se hará cargo de lo demás de
poner en su lugar los signos positivos y
negativos